you ready I'm ready are you ready okay
Barbara Ballard Breen and her team are
here to create a virtual version of a
historic hut that's over 100 years old
in order to help protect it here we go
and she's about to step inside for the
first time I don't even know I was
expecting that it's so beautifully
preserved it's unbelievable and this is
how I left it when they headed out to
the pond
I says if they're just waiting for
everyone to come back on October 24th
1911 British explorer Robert Falcon
Scott and sixteen men left this Hut on
an expedition to the South Pole they
were the second group ever to make it
there but on their way back they were
caught in a blizzard that lasted nine
days on March 29th Scott wrote in his
journal we shall stick it out to the end
but we are getting weaker of course and
the end cannot be far it seems a pity
but I do not think I can write more
months later the party was found frozen
to death over a hundred miles from the
safety of this shelter
amazing it's stunning as preserves so
well I feel like we're the first people
to discover it
God everywhere you look there's just
something unbelievable there boots and
hats on the shelves it's amazing
you can almost feel their present for
you can't you you can you can just
imagine it with people in the banks
sitting around the table sharing a meal
working in the kitchen
the dishes are there sugar
coca oh my god the Illustrated London
News Saturday February 29th 1908 Wow it
cost six months isn't that something
the hut is 25 feet by 50 feet and
Barbara's team has just a few hours
inside it to complete their mission I'm
scared for what how about you go down
the center aisle come this way and see
how we go okay we're making a virtual
reality mosaic of the inside of this Hut
by having multiple cameras at multiple
angles and multiple Heights when we
process them on a computer later we can
get a 3d image of the hut we take
thousands of images and then I stitch
those images together to create 3d ortho
mosaics we actually have to make every
second count
because we've only got a limited amount
of time here it's a very remote location
we've got one shot at this so it's a
little bit nerve-wracking but we want to
do it right because we can't come back
again